c'est un cri d alerte lancée par maud
kino cette maman de 36 ans essaye
désespérément depuis le 17 avril dernier
de récupérer son fils farhad louis l'an
dernier 6 114 enfants était inscrit au
fichier des personnes recherchées suite
à un enlèvement parental âgé d'à peine
cinq ans le garçon a été enlevé par son
père est emmené au sultanat doman à 6000
km de la france
elle a dit et est
aujourd'hui difficile pour moi de faire
pression sur son ex compagnon puisqu'il
n'est autre que le fils de malik
sulaiman al marri le ministre de
l'intérieur à oman ce soir à la choisit
tpm paix pour tenter de retrouver son
fils farhad
ea nous recevons donc la maman mode qui
nous la poire bon c'est évidemment
évidemment terrible on peut si on a
compris que le plus papa est un
personnage politique donc ça doit
compliquer encore plus les choses
d'abord comment vous vous êtes
rencontrés avec monsieur
je vivais déjà au maine j'ai beaucoup
voyagé dans ma carrière puisque je suis
architecte d'intérieur et on s'est
rencontré un mois avant que je que je
quitte oman pour mon prochain contrat en
arabie saoudite
et j'ai rencontré dans le désert
que quand vous mettez vos relations avec
avec cet homme c'était compliqué c'était
belle relation ou
cependant c'était une relation enfin une
relation tout à fait normal il avait
étudié dix ans à miami donc il était il
était très ouvert enfin il était tout ce
qu'il ya de plus normal c'est à dire
parce que dans le cas de petites
mahmoudi jamais sans ma fille pareil le
papa était voilà civilisé expérience y
avait eu aucun signe avant coureur
revenant pas et on me dit toujours m tu
avais tu n'avais pas vu venir non rien
du tout ah non non il était très ouvert
et il respecté mon
mon style de vie occidental et il n'y
avait pas deux sinon je veux bien
entendu je ne l'aurais pas épouser donc
il n'était pas violent avec vous non
jamais non donc c'est uniquement à
propos de la cus qui a fait que vous
êtes séparés alors
c'est un peu compliqué en tout cas il
n'était pas violent jusqu'au début au
début et après ça a commencé ça a
commencé en lune de miel
alors ça n'a pas toujours été ça pas
commencé de manière intense donc c'était
quand il est allé crescendo on va dire
et
et ça enfin
il ya eu plusieurs plusieurs fois où il
a failli me tuer donc ça a été vraiment
très intense hinault black et au sol ils
m'ont extrêmement violent il était
extrêmement où il ya eu des problèmes ce
comportement a changé il est passé de 6
à 10 ans un mari violent on a on a on a
vécu un drame notre premier enfant un
garçon est mort à la naissance
et donc à partir de ce moment là les
violences se sont intensifiées
mais c'est vraiment dès le lendemain de
la naissance de phan huy que déjà je le
reconnaissais plus physiquement enfin il
y avait un côté schizophrénique où il
avait complètement changé
jusqu'à changer de visage et hélas
c'était c'était c'était une intensifie
une intensification merci
c'était c'était très très violent alors
donc vous vous séparez vous remets en
france non non non non non ça et ça
c'est pas du tout passé comme ça et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai été
relaxé
j'ai été poursuivi pour pour kidnapping
pour des placements et licier de mineur
par ascendant pour soustraction et j'ai
été relaxé donc je ne voulais pas qu'il
n'a p ce qui s'est passé c'est que
j'étais
j'étais en vacances alors avant de
raconter ça je vais peut-être raconter
quand même en mai 2019 on a une
enfin il a un accès un accès de violence
et ça a été ça a été la fois où il a été
le plus violent de toutes les fois et
j'ai réussi à m'échapper et j'appelle
mon ami de l'époque qui était
ambassadeur de france à oman qui était
proche et qui savaient ce que je faisais
ce que je subissais et il m'a dit viens
immédiatement à l'ambassade on va
recevoir avec la consule et donc j'ai
expliquées en détail et à la fin ils
m'ont dit voilà compte tenu des très
bonnes relations entre la france et au
mans on peut pas se permettre de de
mettre en péril ses relations pour pour
une ressortissante française tf1 que
mais qui est quand même en danger
visiblement conquis en danger ouais donc
la politique prendra soin d'attribuer
absolument et est en fait moi ce que la
raison pour laquelle je suis allé voir
ce n'était pas pour lui demander de
m'extraire feint de ne sortir de domagné
de me ramener en france n'était pas
l'objectif ce que je demandais en fait
j'avais besoin d'appuis et j'avais
besoin de montrer à ma belle famille que
je suis soutenue et que je ne suis pas
tout seul et qui peuvent pas faire ce
qu'ils veulent de moi donc vous n'aviez
aucun soutien de l'ambassade quand vous
a clairement dit il y en aura pas vous
vous retrouvez seul à oman ou en
sélection de dix ans vous avez divorcé
vous demandez divorce alors j'ai depuis
m'a quasiment un peu de temps après la
naissance de mon fils j'ai demandé le
divorce
donc je me suis allé voir trois avocats
différent ils me disaient tous d'accord
très bien on va faire ça ça ça qu'elle
est non de votre mari non je donné le
nom à valence désolé on peut pas vous
représenter je vous prendrai pas le
risque annonce donc en fait j'étais
vraiment j'ai été emprisonné dans enfin
c'était un enfer je ne sentais pas en
sécurité dans ma propre maison mon mari
était extrêmement violent de jour comme
de nuit sous les yeux de mon fils
et personne personne pour m'aider
finalement parce que j'ai oui j'étais
soutenu par mes amis mais qu'est ce
qu'ils pouvaient faire donc c'était
vraiment une situation où je n'avais
plus d'espoir et je ne voyais pas
comment j'allais m'en sortir enfermé à
la maison à oman way abandonné par
évidemment la belle famille on ne parle
même pas ouais votre ex mari violent
menaçant est-ce que déjà le le petit
était un était un un enjeu et un chien
chantage des bus depuis le début il me
disait une dizaine situes tu pars tu te
reverra plus jamais ton fils donc
c'était toujours ça a été le gros
chantage affectif et puis en fait au
final gt gt
gt prête à
vivre ce cauchemar pour pour mon fils je
j'ai jamais voulu parce qu'on me disait
toujours mais pourquoi tu rentres pas en
france déjà parce que mon passeport a
été retenu dans le coffre fort déjà et
puis la raison principale c'est que j'ai
jamais voulu couper le lien entre entre
monfils et entourent notre fils et son
père et donc j'étais prête à vivre à
endurer ce cauchemar qu'est ce qui fait
que vous avez décidé de finalement
quitter oman alors j'ai pas quitter oman
ce qui s'est passé c'est que je suis en
vacances en italie avec mon fils et j'ai
été accusée à tort d'adultère d'adultère
et de boire de l'alcool qui sont alors
ça peut paraître dérisoire en france
mais ce sont des crimes très graves
ouais au sultanat d'oman et puis bon si
on fait des recherches selon la
charrière dont c'est la peine de mort
et puis il faut savoir aussi que et ça
c'est une information que j'ai eue de
mon avocate au malaise comme un simple
soupçons d'adultère suffit pour être
coupable et sachant que de toute façon
le gouvernement c'était la famille de
mon de mon mari voilà et donc quand j'ai
été accusé de ça mon mari me dit
j'arrive de suite récupérer afin dé le
ramener à oman et tu ne le reverra plus
jamais
donc là à ce moment là je m'évanouis jeu
reprend ensuite mes esprits et je prends
mon téléphone je demande à google l'aîné
des jeux je tape avocat spécialiste du
droit de la famille à paris
et j'en appelle à peu près une dizaine
je leur raconte bit fait l'histoire et
ils me disent tous que vous prenez
faites vos sacs faites vos bagages et
vont rentrer immédiatement en france
parce que vous ne reverrez plus jamais
votre fils et c'est ce que j'ai fait
donc vous êtes rentré sans le petit
d'accord à côté donc vous êtes vous
installé à bordeaux
la savoure prenait une vie normale non
non je reprends pas de vie normale je
lui ai d'abord annoncé que je ne
rentrais pas à oman avec notre fils
donc par message je lui explique que
suite aux fausses accusations qui ont
été faites à mon encontre je mettrai ma
vie en danger et donc celle de mon fils
par extension en rentrant et donc
j'avais pris la décision de rester en
france et que mes avocats les le
contacter pour le divorce que j'allais
demander le divorce et je lui ai demandé
de devenir de venir rendre visite à la
fad et à la suite de ça il a mis quatre
mois avant de venir
disait que c'était un piège et que
j'allais faire arrêter
et au bout de quatre mois et donc en
novembre 2019 un beau jour enfin
j'allais chercher fayyad à l'école et on
serait interpellée dans la rue c'était
lui et il avait il avait juste avant
d'arriver à bordeaux il avait il était
passé par paris où il a pris un très bon
cabinet d'avocats les meilleurs et il a
porté plainte pour pour soustraction et
lycées de mineur par ascendant qu'en
fait ils vous reprochent d'avoir
kidnappé le petit césar alors que c'est
ce qui va faire lui a eu le fait qu'en
celle du 7 avril c'est ça oui alors donc
à la suite de cette plainte
alors j'étais au courant de la plainte
mais bon il s'était rien passé de
particulier et à la le jour de la fin du
confinement je me réveillais avec mon
fils donc trois ans à l'époque je me
réveillais un samedi matin à 8 heures et
les commissaires des commissaires frappe
à la porte et donc là il faut une
perquisition
ils effectuent une perquisition à mon
domicile donc y retourne mon appartement
et il ment lève il me relève sous les
yeux de mon fils qui hurlait la police
la police amène maman en prison
il hurle il pleurait il est donc là je
suis amenée en garde à vue en france en
france je suis interrogée pendant 12
heures
et je suis ensuite placé en garde à vue
où je passe la nuit et le matin je suis
amené au tribunal et à la suite de
l'audience la juge manon ce que je suis
mise en examen et placé sous contrôle
judiciaire quand j'ai interdiction de
quitter la nouvelle aquitaine qu'il
confisqué mon passeport et celui de mon
fils et que je dois aller signer au
commissariat une fois par semaine et
alors là c'est le évidemment ça se
renverse contre vous mais à quel moment
votre ex par l'ex mari récupère le petit
alors ben c'est justement à la suite de
ça j'ai été mise en examen et donc après
deux ans de d'investigation les
gendarmes tout ça c'est 17 avril mais le
12 je sais c'est en fait c'est le 12
avril dernier 2 le 12 avril 2022 je suis
relax et donc de ce chef d'accusation d'
donc je suis relaxé et donc à la suite
de cette relaxe
il était persuadé que j'allais aller en
prison dont 15 aces qui disait à tout le
monde elle va aller en prison et donc je
suis relax et donc son plan n'a pas
abouti et donc à la suite de ça le
dimanche le 17 avril un dimanche matin
il vient récupérer notre fils il
m'expliquait va l'amener à paris à
disneyland et je n'ai plus de nouvelles
donc le jour même je me suis pas
inquiété
et puis je les imagine et à disneyland
en train de s'amuser est-ce que vous
n'allez pas un doute peu après tout ce
qui s'était passé de celle ci alors
j'avais plus qu'un doute et j'avais
alerté les autorités jeu ça fait deux
ans que je me battais pour obtenir une
interdiction de sortie du territoire
s'ils mettaient à chaque fois refusées
alors que j'avais j'avais des preuves et
c'est un risque qui était clairement
avéré enfin qui allait se produire en
tout cas et personne ne m'a en fait ils
attendaient que l'enfant soit qu'il n'a
mais pour pouvoir comprendre que
effectivement le faire mal kidnappé
aujourd'hui le plus petit avec son père
à one et kin 1 comment il va et quels
sont vos vos recours éventuels pour
essayer de défaut - moi de pouvoir le
revoir parce que ça va être très
compliqué
il va très mal
j'arrive à enfin le père son père mme le
laisse lui parler de temps en temps donc
c'est bien sûr quand il en a envie
à chaque fois fade pleurs et ils vous
demandent de venir le chercher
il ya deux semaines il ya deux semaines
j'ai ma pelle et il était en pleurs et
il attend que son père quitte la pièce
et là il me dit maman mon père il m'a
battue m'a fait très mal de temps que je
lui dis mais qu'est ce qu'est ce qui
s'est passé il me dit oui il voulait que
je prenne le banc ce matin et je ne
voulais pas semblé bon alors il m'a
frappé et il m'a poussé très fort contre
la mémoire et j'ai eu très mal on m'a
dit je t'en supplie maman s'il te plaît
mais avoue chercher je montre
voilà que je me sens bien entendu en
puissante puisque je ne peux pas y aller
parce que je serais je serais
immédiatement arrêté alors quelle est la
solution
la france ça vous dit quoi on s'est
complètement désintéressé alors grâce
grâce à mon réseau personnel j'ai réussi
à
contacter chaque ministre et le
président de la république emmanuel
macron qui donc des personnes de mon
réseau et de mes contacts les ont
contactés personnellement donc ils sont
tous informés la situation depuis deux
mois ont depuis enlèvement et
personne ne fait rien personne ne fait
rien parce que vous comprenez la france
est au monde très très bonne relation
surtout économique balla gaye a surtout
bien non je t'assure garçons ben oui
mais
c'est surtout je joue en quel jugement
vous avez eu pour que vous retrouvez mis
en examen c'est quoi le jugement que
vous avez vu
reprocher d'avoir en fait à ce serait
très difficile d'avoir ce genre de
jugement enlèvement ses intérieurs
disons que j'ai été relaxé parce que
j'ai réussi bien entendu à prouver que
j'étais en danger mais que en fait je
sauvais mamie et c'est donc par
extension celle de mon fils est
aujourd'hui c'est quoi votre espoir
aucun nettoyer c'est quoi les recours et
aucun recours à longwy aimé y est encore
en cours sa part me président de la
république des sucs d'interférer sur
bien sûr mais moi je ne vais pas vous
pas rentrer dans le sas et que l'état
français ne peux pas vous aider vous
avez un jugement de divorce tu poses qui
établit deux pas de convention
une garde partagée une garde partagée et
garder ton juridique quand même alors il
ya une garde partagée mais qui est en
train de devenir une guerre de exclusive
le 21 le 21 janvier bon ben on lui pour
moi pour vous attend donc donc il est
clairement hors la loi oui bien à nommer
un mandat d'arrêt international qui a
été délivré un don qu'il est clairement
hors la loi alors on se passer la
question n'y a pas de convention
la seule solution c'est une intervention
politique ouais et ça parce que si le 21
vous devez le récupérer quand vous le
dites et qui l'amendement d'arrêt il
vous le rendra pas malgré le résultat
vous êtes c'est ça le nom bien sûr oui
non mais bien dans ton dur
puisqu'on est là je pense que l'espoir
franchement cette histoire liée d'abord
c'est pas vous n'êtes pas un cas unique
soit en personne aujourd'hui
concrètement comment est ce que on peut
vous aider ce qui a un message à faire
passer ce que
vous adressez pas au président macro
mais son épouse assise mais voilà son
rouge oui moi tellement aux ministres
des affaires étrangères sera évidemment
de la diplomatie donc on imagine que
c'est compliqué mais je veux bien qu'il
y ait des enjeux économiques avec avait
avec oman mais honnêtement il ya un
petit garçon là j'ai oublié de préciser
que le passeport de mon fils est
toujours au tribunal sous scellés et
donc pour le kidnapper il est passé par
l'espagne en il est resté 48 heures et
l'ambassadeur de hohmann à madrid à
délivrer un laissez passer mais non
vous avez tout contre vous mais je te
dise
le je pense que le message le plus
important c'est vraiment bien que
mais je pense que ça paraît évident
surtout en 2020 2 1 enfants à besoins et
de sa mère son père et de son père et je
ne les jamais privé de deux de voir son
père et j'ai tout fait j'ai tout fait
pour que ça aille dans ce sens là moi
j'étais c'était j'ai été obligé de me
sauver et de là mais je pense que c'est
très important de faire passer ce
message là un enfant a besoin autant
d'une mère que c'est un père bien
entendu si si enfin voilà dans le dans
l'éventualité que chacun soit sain et
voilà bien entendu donc ça c'est le
premier message sur lequel je veux et
puis par le deuxième c'est et des mois
et des mois vous écouter on va essayer
on va tout faire poser de vous aider on
va suivre également le dossier j'espère
que le matrix marie et les ministres we
will miss non alors il est il travaille
pour les renseignements et il est c'est
le fils du bras droit sultan kabous qui
est mort il ya de sultan
français revoit tout faire vous vous
aider les recéder passer nous voir on
vous embrasse et demain et des dommages
pense que toutes les équipes et on
suivait j'espère vraiment que le petit
garçon pour avoir son sa mère évidemment
piller son père aussi merci beaucoup
mode